lance berkman who was inducted into the
astros hall of fame today throughout the
ceremonial first hit lance mccullers jr
who's been very good for houston this
season 11 wins four losses a 3.19
earned run average and now it's jared
walsh left-handed hitting first baseman
he's batting 272 334 on base percentage
26 home runs and 82 runs batted in for
walsh comes in with an 11-game hit
streak after an rbi double in the first
inning yesterday
he hit a home run in the first game on
friday
no score two on
and one out in the top of the first the
one two
and that is strike three call on the
outside corner with the hook
wall shaking his head as he walks back
to the third base dugout and mccullers
picks up his first punch out two away
fletcher at third ohtani at second for
luis rengifo he had a two-run homer
yesterday batting 183 on the year 220 on
base percentage four homers and 10 rbi
switch hitter batting left first pitch
and that's a ground ball right back to
mccullers jocks halfway to first base
under hands to yuli and the inning is
over mccullers slaps his right hand into
the palm of his glove as he jogs off as
the angels are turned aside despite the
first two batters of the inning reaching
and after a half inning angels nothing
astros coming up jaime berea gets the
start for the angels today comes in with
the two and three record 5.16 already
the angels right hander will go for them
so the astros have two on with one out
for julie guriel so now eule guerrielle
bats he sends one up the middle for a
base hit altuve heading to third he'll
be waved around marsh's throw will not
be in time astros take a one-nothing
lead euleg ariel rbi number 74.
so here is diaz one for four in the
series with a pair of rbis bases loaded
two outs two-two pitch and he got him
swinging a slider struck him out and
that will end the inning
now it's kurt suzuki's turn the angels
catcher
he's batting 218 286 on base percentage
four homers 14 rbis for suzuki
mcculler's the 1-2 to suzuki swing and a
miss chase the slider off the plate away
second strikeout for lance went away now
juan lagares standing in right-handed
hitting right fielder lagara is hitting
232 259 on base percentage five homers
33 rbis oh and one the count to juan
lagardes
mccullars delivers and that's a ground
ball left side right at correa at a
second for one el toobi on the first
that's a 643 double play emma cullers
gets out of trouble yet again
chaz mccormick is up now number eight
hitter for the astros and here's the
pitch and there's a big swing and a miss
on a
rising fastball there and down on
strikes goes mccormick man mark team
maldonado is a guy you just attack he's
four for 33 this year against the angels
that's a 1 21 average
so berea is ready and here comes his 1-2
and that is a called third strike that
was a fastball right in there and
maldonado a strikeout victim a pair in
the inning three in a row for berea who
got the final out in the
bottom of the first on a strikeout and
now altuve will be the next batter with
two away and here comes the 3-2 he got
him swinging
put him down to one knee chasing that
pitch and altuve
the third batter to strike out in the
inning against the angel starter burrill
who struck out the last four overall
fletcher singled his last time up one
for 29 in his last eight games now
here's the one two
and he got him strike three with the
fastball
got it away that time on fletcher he
reached for it there's running fifo
got it out back to the pitcher his last
time up
breaking ball got him strike three
when riding low and in on ren tifo and
he swung right over the top four
strikeouts now for lance one in each
inning and that'll bring up brandon
marsh he was hit by a pitch as last time
up
here's the one two
got him strike three that breaking ball
lowing in marsh swings over the top of
it fifth strikeout for lance and there's
two away
correa free agent at the end of the year
guessing his dance card will be pretty
full
fastball gets him looking this is a
ledmis diaz
get some swinging that's number six in a
season high in strikeouts for jaime
berea rigman is flight out and grounded
out and here's the 2-2 he swings at this
one and lifts it in the air in a right
center field but marsh has a beat on it
he'll make the catch in right center he
was about six seven feet from the rim of
the track but
pretty much a routine out to wrap up the
inning so for the second time in four
innings the astros will leave the bases
loaded still a one-run game as we head
to the fifth one nothing houston john
legaris the
nine-hole hitter will be the next batter
logaris
oh did he get that one you better
believe it
that one is gone
one gone and this game is tied
every once in a while you'll hang a
slider and when you hang a slider that
goes to the barrel the bats what a swing
good swing path for lagarus just like
that
tied at one
sixth home run of the year for the
angels outfielder
now it's david fletcher's turn with one
out of nobody
on that ball hit hard diving catch by
carlos correa
takes a hit away from david fletcher
with a diving catch to his right
and now it's kyle tucker's turn he's
walked and lined out to deep left pitch
on the way and tucker hits it in the air
pretty well to right center going back
on it lagares at the wall looking up see
you later
into the astros bullpen kyle tucker with
a two-run blast and it's a three-to-one
astros lead
and he just keeps breaking
jared walsh the batter he is one for two
with a single three infielders and a
triangle right side two two swing and a
miss good curve ball down and in and
walsh goes down on strikes
six k's for mccullough's second time
he's gotten walsh two out there's luis
ringo over two a ground out and a
strikeout
colors one out away from completing six
innings
delivers a 2-2 swing and a mess all
curveballs syrenne heapho and he strikes
him out seven strikeouts
for lance mccullers jr including
back-to-back case to cap off a 1-2-3
inning through five and a half astros
three angels one julie guriel who has
not been an easy out
will be the batteries three for three
today he's
driven in one of their three runs he
scored one of their three runs
three singles for him
two and two
line to right field but doris he slips
he falls down
it gets over his head
bregman had to hold up is he gonna go
he's trying to go home and score the
play at the plate he is
out at the plate
that's carlos correa over three here's
the next pitch and that's a shot right
up the middle but caught there by marsh
hit right at him i think marsh forgot
that was the final out makes the catch
on that one and that is how the inning
will end
now it's jared walsh to the plate always
dangerous one for three today with a
single he has struck out twice
1-1
and that's lined in the left alvarez
coming in and makes the catch moving
toward the line
caught it about letter high well struck
by walsh but alvarez didn't have to go
far in the ending is over angel strand a
couple and after seven and a half astros
three angels one jack mayfield final
hope for the angels astros lead three to
one one one
ground ball left side correa to his left
he gathers it in throws to first and
that is the ball game
the houston astros take two out of three
from the angels winning this afternoon